[Music]
next up as far as we understand the
russian military campaign in the ukraine
is not going according to plan
has putin made an enormous mistake and
if so what should the west's response be
i'm joined now by dr mike martin who is
professor of war studies at king's
college london and the mail on sunday
sunday columnist peter hitchens
mike i will start with you um
quite recently you tweeted
i'm going to call this i think the
russian armed forces are going to
collapse
followed by putin leaving power i can't
say this for certain obviously but i
think this is the eventuality can you
give us a bit of a breakdown uh as to
why you think that
i can
um
the first question when you're launching
any kind of military action is to have
your military resources matched up to
your strategic goals um putin's
strategic goal here requires about a
million troops the overthrow of the
ukrainian government and the replace of
replacement of it by someone more
favorable to russia um they've rolled up
with about 200 000 troops so completely
mismatched uh resources to their aims
that's the first thing the second thing
is as has become clear to absolutely
everybody
the russian army
is um
unable to do its own logistics unable to
repair its vehicles
um has plenty of desertions has
conscripts
and that's not to say that the
ukrainians are not also suffering losses
but the ukrainians are fighting on home
territory with the support of the
population and their morale is sky high
whereas the morale of the russians is
about as low as it can get i mean within
the last week they've lost two two-star
generals
um which means that something's going
very very wrong and all of those things
that i've described there morale
equipment and personnel are really what
makes up the fighting power
of a military and if you look at the two
sides the ukrainians have got most of
the elements of what make up the
fighting power of the military and the
russians don't
and so the question is what happens if
they do get routed in the field or they
get fought to a standstill and
effectively start getting picked off to
an even greater degree than they are now
well i think the problem is that putin
relies to a great degree on succeeding
in this and so if he fails or at the
extreme the russian military gets routed
as has happened in some small skirmishes
but if it happens at an operational
level in ukraine i think putin stays a
numbered
to what extent do you think our
perspective might be warped somewhat by
the fact that most of our information
that we're getting is coming from
ukrainian sources which are not always
altogether reliable
that's that's absolutely true
and i think that if you look at for
example the
u.s
military's assessments of the situation
they seem to
let's just take casualties for instance
they say that the
russians have suffered between two and
four thousand casualties which by the
way is is much much more than the u.s
suffered in 20 years in afghanistan
they also say the ukrainians have
suffered approximately
similar numbers but come back to the
calculus the russians are
working at the end of their supply lines
in hostile terrain and the ukrainians
are operating on home grounds with i
mean it's a country of 44 million people
we have an armed forces of let's say 350
000 plus territorial defense units and
and so on and so forth um there is a
much more
the supply of labor for the ukrainians
is much greater than that um available
to the russians so even if it was a
one-for-one
um attrition rate um the ukrainians
would eventually win that mathematical
contest
peter uh let me bring you in we've heard
a fair bit in recent days about putin's
hubris how he's miscalculated greatly uh
are you beginning to get a bit concerned
that there's a little bit of western
hubris
uh creeping into uh the the the
conversation uh here well not so far i
think i mean the action by putin was
plainly mad uh and
was almost certainly
would have been opposed by
almost all of his closest advisors who
have any sense if he'd share it with
them uh it has all the characteristics
of of a
flailing
last throw by somebody who's
lost all sense of reality and it's not
surprising if it goes wrong i don't know
how wrong it's gone or how
how wrong it will go partly because i
don't actually know what the actual
objective of the attack was supposed to
be in the first place i'd never be able
to work that out does he seriously want
to take the whole of ukraine and hold it
down how could he do that anyway the one
of the things which fascinates me is in
my
long arguments over the years with the
new cold war merchants who've been
saying we've got to be prepared for
russia to behave badly i've said over
and over again russia has an economy
this size italy and its armed forces
aren't up to much
i would have thought that a large part
of my position has been demonstrated as
factual by this performance so they it's
it's not a first-rate army as far as one
can see
nor
as has been rightly said is it big
enough for
any of the tasks it might have been set
out to do so thought it's hubris on the
other hand in general uh it's always
wise to stick to what you actually know
and i'm not at all sure we actually know
very much about this war at all the
amount of first-hand reporting though
heroic where it appears it's very it's
very small uh and the the knowledge that
we have i don't know i've sorry i've
been brought out over the years not
entirely to trust intelligence service
accounts of what's going on wait see
what really happens but i don't i just
don't think
uh that the the russia was ever powerful
enough uh to to to seize uh ukraine and
hold it and i i don't think it is now
and i suspect that what we're
discovering is that it's military forces
are not that good and have not improved
all that much from the time when they
were that awful bunch of drunks who who
who pretty much uh massacred everyone in
chechnya so i don't know but i i don't i
don't think it would necessarily be
hubristic to say judging on by their
performance so far they're not doing
very well
were you surprised peter when i mean you
talked about intelligence being doubtful
uh it seemed that western intelligence
particularly american intelligence was
absolutely spot on uh to certainly to my
surprise about putin's plans for
invasion well exactly and isn't that
such a shock after all the rubbish
they've been talking for the past 30 or
40 years over and over again for them
actually to get something right you must
forgive those of us who weren't entirely
convinced by it
it's not a thing that intelligence is
especially good at so yes
congratulations to them they got one
right let's see if they can keep it up
uh mike yesterday uh president vladimir
zelensky was in spoke uh by video link
to the house of commons
to sort of rapturous
applause um do you worry perhaps that we
are um
getting a little bit obviously we are on
ukraine's side but perhaps the the
political class in this country is
becoming a little bit blind as to the
reality because we're getting slightly
swept up
in cheerleading uh the ukrainian effort
um
well i mean i don't think the political
class is up to much um in the country at
the moment
um i i think there's a there's a bigger
question about ukraine which is what's
the strategic outcome that we want we've
spoken plenty about what putin's
strategic games are but it seems to me
that uh in the same way that putin
wanted to redesign the european security
order so do we actually the outcome that
we want from ukraine is
i think you know the sovereignty and
territorial integrity of ukraine being
respected of course but actually i think
we want a bit of a redesign of the
european security order and that
probably involves putin not being part
of that now how we achieve that goal
exactly how you apply leverage obviously
you know a change of leadership in
russia is an affair for the russians but
of course we can apply leverage to that
i think that that really must be
the outcome of this conflict and what is
more
every action that the west that nato
that the u.s takes here is being watched
by china so we have to not only solve
the uh you know the global uh sorry the
sort of regional security challenge here
but we have to have an eye on the global
security architecture because china will
be looking very carefully at
what's going on here so this recent
fuffle over migs will they won't they
you know because someone said on twitter
as schrodinger's mix
um that's watched by china and things
are interesting so if you do go in 10
days later they'll be very unified for
the first 10 days and then they'll start
arguing over things like mix i think we
need to be very very very careful about
things like that there's a lot more
than ukraine at stake here we're talking
not just about the regional but also the
global security order and so we have to
get this right and i do worry that the
quality of leadership that we have at
the moment
specifically in the uk
probably is not able to think in big
picture terms and understand exactly how
to
influence the micro
by that i mean what's happening in
ukraine
to achieve the grand strategic outcomes
that we want
peter what do you think the grand
strategic outcomes are the the ones that
we want
well i don't know um
what i want and what um the united
states want for instance might be
different things but uh the the thing is
the the invasion has changed everything
now it's it i think it's almost
certainly made putin's actual objective
impossible which is he had hoped to
avoid the implementation of the
brzezinski doctrine which is if you can
take ukraine away from russia russia
becomes permanently a minor power and
this this isn't a matter of territory
it's a matter really of who controls
ukraine as long as ukraine is
non-aligned uh things bumped along on a
relatively even keel but since 2014 when
the west back to putch
in kiev and
install the government which leaned very
sharply to the west
russia has been a state of panic about
this which has now come to full fruition
but by failing to do anything about it
in this this this mad spasm i think
probably just as as putin's actions in
uh particularly in the uh lugansk and
donetsk regions and the the separation
of the russian areas have made ukraine
more ukrainian
this attack on ukraine will make it far
more likely that ukraine will become a
permanent member of the of the western
security and economic structure and
there's no chance at all of russia being
able to win it back by diplomacy so he's
lost that battle and
those who wanted very much to pursue the
belittling of russia uh going right back
to uh
to the wolfowitz doctrine of 1992 have
got their way
the chances of russia ever ever rising
again is even a major regional power are
now pretty much done for i think so
we've got that and for the rest of it i
i would say that
it's a simple uh summary of our wisest
policy anybody's wise's policy under
these circumstances don't interrupt your
enemy while he's making a mistake uh
it really and truly this is a colossal
mistake as to start introducing no-fly
zones or or sending or sending polish
migs to ukraine under the circumstances
would be crazy thing to do
mike do you get the impression that i
mean there are certainly people in the
west who are
talking about the possible involvement
of poland uh there's been all the talk
about the sky and the no-fly zone and
all the various dangers of that do you
think there's a danger that uh we will
interrupt our enemy while he's making a
mistake and then cause uh a much bigger
and wider problem
yeah so here's the problem um hundreds
if not thousands of ukrainian civilians
are dying as we speak and
i don't know
we might get to a point where a hundred
thousand ukrainians are dead within a
fairly short period of time ukrainian
civilians we've just seen
a maternity hospital has been bombed
now
the problem is that grand strategy
doesn't actually care about such things
as reprehensible as that is and i know
that this is an unpopular view
the problem is that the
western politicians responding to
pundits and political pressure may
indeed do something stupid that is
counter to what their grand strategic
interests are and so to take some of
these examples you know no-fly zone nuts
um just work out exactly how to apply
leverage on russia without giving them
excuses to up the ante poland getting
involved over these migs i mean the
irony is the
the migs have a marginal at best uh
military
uh uh benefits you know very difficult
to get them over there and all the rest
of it like and marginal um far more
useful would be a lorry load of
anti-tank missiles as we've seen right
all the russian convoys are strung out
having great great effect and you only
need one bloke or woman um
with an anti-tank missile to cause
absolute habit so far more useful and so
the only possible reason to do these
migs is to have a kind of political
signaling effect
and that would be some sort of uh
basically it sends a signal that we're
unified we're pulling together we're
swapping out migs for u.s f-16s we're
sending the mixed ukraine it sends this
kind of we are nato is unified signal to
russia but the way they've handled it is
sent exactly the opposite signal um so
we need you know and again i sort of
worry this it comes back to i think a
quality of political leadership um
question um that i that i mentioned
earlier
peter if nato is invigorated uh is that
bad news
well i'm the wrong person to ask since
no i think you're the right person long
believe that nato should have been wound
up in 1991 and its continued existence
has been a menace uh i i i would say
that the these
events predicted as they were by by
george kennan uh in 1998 more or less
and by jaeger geidar the russian liberal
politician
and by many many other experts on
strategy said if you if you expand nato
if you push nato towards towards russia
you will cause the most terrible
problems and you will create in russia a
resurgence of revenge's opinion and uh
indeed by implication you will create
someone like vladimir putin well we've
done that now
and as it happens it appears that we
might be going to get away with it
without too much terrible damage i the
point about
civilian casualties is well made but my
view is that if you intensify war there
will be more of those casualties uh a
no-fly zone for instance would
undoubtedly lead to many many more
casualties and almost certainly beyond
the borders of ukraine any sort of
widening of the war would be likely to
do that i i would very much hope that we
could we could
find at some stage fairly soon uh a way
in which we could end the slaughter
altogether the real danger is that is
that ukraine now slips into a condition
of permanent war
that the russians won't leave that no
deal is done that nobody wants to
compromise uh that all its major cities
become permanent fallujahs and people
just die and die and die and millions of
people have to become refugees perhaps
for the rest of their lives or corpses
and what would be the point of that i
think there has to be a moment which we
have to consider what is the uh how how
many ukrainians we're prepared to
sacrifice for the purposes of our of our
pride uh in refusing to make any kind of
deal and obviously in saying look you
attacks you're in the wrong
but that doesn't necessarily mean that
we that we don't desire peace for the
human beings who actually live in
ukraine which i think any any christian
person does and any civilized person
does
may i respond to just some of peter's
points ready with that
yeah yeah so on the question of nato
expansion um
obviously we're all familiar with these
arguments but that presupposes that the
traditional buffer states if you like in
eastern europe the baltics poland or
ukraine etc i don't have a say in the
matter and quite clearly all of them
want to be part of nato they don't want
to be dominated by russia so this sort
of you know
yalta-esque napkin we're going to draw a
line and keep you guys buffer states
irrespective of whether you want to be
members of nato or the eu i think
undermines
one of the central planks if you like
that makes the west attractive which is
democracy people get to choose and so on
and so forth
on the question of um
how many people in ukraine um need to
die
um
respectfully i'm not sure that that's a
question because
in the sense that
if if we don't get this right if we
don't get the security order right we
may well be sending
uh british people to die
and the you know
the question for our leaders um in
britain and their job of course is to
protect the interests of britain and
british people is that
we should we should not be getting
ourselves into situations where perhaps
british people are going to die
peter you respond to that well i
wouldn't disagree with that i'd be
appalled if if british
british military personnel got directly
involved in this and i at the moment i
could see no cons possible justification
for it going back from out to the to the
nato question
if you really believe that then
presumably you'd be arguing for taiwan
to be given membership of nato which
nobody would do because it would be
obviously a stupid thing to do
as it happens we in the west don't even
recognize taiwan as a country let alone
allowed to join in the alliances because
we're too scared of
china the whole history of nato
expansion is that it was not
the the idea that was demanded by the
the the nations involved is pretty
slender uh it was
it was rammed through the senate uh in
the late 1990s by bill clinton and a
load of
neocons and also with a huge amount of
very heavy lobbying by american arms
manufacturers this isn't some sort of
socialist worker stuff all this was
reported at the time by the new york
times about the same time that george
that i didn't interrupt you about the
same time that george cannon came out of
retirement to say for heaven's sake
don't do this stupid thing
the the the three baltic republics
gained their independence from from
russia in 1991
and they they they did not enter nato
for
several years
after that during which i know of no
material threat ever made to their
independence so the whole thing that's
that it was demanded by these poor
countries left in limbo is pretty thin
the truth that it was very seriously
warned against by intelligent
highly pro-western uh strategists who
who thought that it was a foolish action
on our own account is beyond dispute i
can think of no other cause in history
that could conceivably unite noam
chomsky and henry kissinger but both of
them say that the expansion of nato was
a stupid thing to do and both of them
write
i'm so sorry i wasn't interrupting i was
actually saying i i was agreeing with
you at a time you could interrupt me to
agree with me that's okay in the future
but i didn't think
necessarily what you were going to do
people don't often do that
one very small point on taiwan um it's
the north atlantic treaty organization
so to
taiwan would be would be a bit
crazy that
if i could just point out
sorry so it's a very important point
here i'm sorry if i hang on if i may if
you're interrupting um what we have seen
recently though um is actually we've
seen a slow edging towards the
integration of taiwan within an east
asian alliance system so we've actually
seen recently japan um who of course um
does have a a pretty uh robust
securities treaty with the united states
japan has recently said that taiwanese
um um keeping taiwan separate from the
people's republic of china is in its
national security interest so it won't
have made those announcements without
first coordinating with the u.s and you
can start to see an almost world war one
esque chain of alliance systems in east
asia that although there isn't a nato
type structure actually we're starting
to get to the point now where with all
these alliances being triggered the us
is going to be dragged into a fight over
taiwan that's very
heartening to know he said sarcastically
a first world war system of alliances is
what we really need but uh by the point
about taiwan not being in the north
atlantic would be terrific if
afghanistan were in the north atlantic
or if libya were in the north atlantic
but nato operations were taking place in
both those places and to claim that it's
limited to to that area is i'm afraid
rather out of date there's obviously no
reason my organization that can put a
force into afghanistan couldn't
incorporate taiwan
this this is a tremendous discussion uh
sadly i'm being told we have to wrap it
up i would actually like to uh both uh
ask you both uh a question i mean
a sort of neat solution for a lot of
people as far as i can see it is that
putin is somehow removed or got rid of
one way or the other um can we be sure
mike and peter can we be sure that what
comes after putin uh would be better as
far as the west is concerned
no
absolutely not could be much worse there
all kinds of horrible things lurking in
moscow which could result from this
don't by any means be confident you're
going to get anything better
mike
and it's great because peter and i can
finish on agreement
we'll finish it there
[Music]
you